even main roads are part of the
battlefield in this conflict
for two days this ukrainian position has
been hammered with rockets fired from
separatist lines further up the road
new debris litters the whole area the
mist adds to the sense of foreboding
this is a scary place
made worse by the sudden quiet after
hours of explosions and the soldiers
don't like it
[Music]
bits of rocket lie next to holes in the
punctured tarmac a direct route to the
russian-backed separatists within sniper
range we can't go further than this uh
these sandbags and this defense position
that road goes right to the separatist
uh controlled area it's not very far
away what's really interesting though
these
uh tank
traps
they say were targeted
um which led them to believe
that um
there's a potential ground uh invasion
this area being planned uh it's never
happened before they were saying and
it's it's interesting because these
lines have been here for years they very
rarely move and it was the first
indicator they've had that actually
maybe
the separatists and the russian forces
are thinking coming down this road and
of course you can hear
explosions around us all the time
we move forward through the mud and snow
of the front line trenches
some lined with wooden planks to stop
the trench walls collapsing
every day now feels much more like world
war one
across this 300 mile demarcation line
rockets and mortars are being fired by
both sides whatever their leaders say
they are both firing
at the nearest point to the separatist
positions the duty soldiers keep a
constant watch
at times they listen to the firing on
other positions trying to identify the
caliber of the incoming rounds
[Music]
across this long battlefield the
soldiers all agree that things are
ramping up things
well it's taken us a long time to get up
to this defensive position because the
fighting has been so intense it was
really intense when we arrived and it's
been intense they say for the last
couple of days and it's really dangerous
here these
these ribbons here
and on this side here
indicate that everything on this side
and on this side is mine
so there's really only this path and
this trench to get in
the soldiers are
really concerned
that there is actually going to be an
attack on them by soldiers rather than
what we've seen which is just the
criss-crossing of missile exchange of
fire but an actual attack on their
positions
so in their bunkers they wait for their
turn to once again take up guard duty in
the trenches
but this is where they retreat when the
rockets are falling
in recent days they've spent a lot of
time here
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine